[تصفيق]
مساء الخير
والى العلا مر السفيه بسيد
جلد التخلف بالحياء فبورك كم مثله عبر
الجلود بثاقب مترفعا عصاه محرك
جميعنا حفظنا الشعر حفظه حين كنا في
المدرسه
لنستاذ امتحانات اللغه العربيه ربما
بعضنا احبه او حفظه عن عن رغبه عن هوايه
احب الادب العربي
بمتعه لكن هل سبق وان استخدمتم الشاعره
وحفظتموه لتتذكروا
تذكروا معلومه علميه ربما ننساها معلومه
طبيه معلومه كيميائيه هل تذكرون متى
الايتان برب البيت بيتانو فهيك سهبتن وكات
النون كانوا
بزماننا حفظناها لينذكر الالكانات العشر
ربما ساعدتنا في حينها
سنحكي في قصتنا اليوم
عن رحله احدهم مر باربعه مشاهد المشهد
الاولى المشهد الاول
لطفل صغير له من العمر خمس او ست سنوات
ذلك الطفل بعوامه المعدوده في سياره
العائله متجها لقضاء العطله الصيفيه مع
عائلته كان والده استاذا في الجامعه محبا
للادب العربي يحفظ كثيرا من ابيات الشعر
ايضا والدته تحب الشعر جده لوالدته اديب
المعروف في حينه وكان ذلك الطفل
مرغما على الجلوس في السياره مع اخواته
وعائلته وشاءت الصدفه ان يلد في تلك
العائله المحبه للشعر وكانت الرحله عباره
عن مساجله شعريه كان والده يقتنص الوقت
ويستثمره
يطلب من ابنائه ان يشاركوه بلعبه هي
المساجله الشعريه في المساجله الشعريه
ياتي فريق ببيت من الشعر وعلى الفريق
الاخر ان ياتي ببيت يبدا حرفه الاول بمن
انتهى اليه راوي او القافيه البيت الاول
كان يقول الفريق الاول قم للمعلم وفيه
التبجيلا كاد المعلم ان يكون رسولا هنا
القافيه لام على الفريق الثاني ان يقول
مثلا بيتا بيت يبدا بحرف اللام ليس الجمال
باثواب تزيننا ان الجمال جمال العلم
والادب القافيه هنا وهكذا ذلك
الطفل كما ذكرنا بعوامه المعدوده يجلس
مراقبا لما ولم يكن لديه لا من الذخيره
اللغويه ولا من الجزيره ولا من الجراه ان
يشارك في تلك اللعبه الاسريه بدا مع اعوام
مدرسته يحفظ بعض القصائد في المدرسه فتجرا
مره بقافيه لحرف الباء وقال لهم بابا بابا
يومك طابا ومره مع الميميه قال لهم ماما
ماما يا انغاما وكان يقبل ذلك منه تشجيعا
وتحفيزا فاحب القصه وبدا يبذل بعض الجهد
ليدرس او ليحفظ ابيات شعريه خارج دراسته
فجاء بدليل للهاتف في تلك الايام كانت
الارقام تكتب ارقام الهاتف تكتب على دليل
ورقي مزين بالحروف الابجديه من الالف الى
الياء
في ذلك الحين لم تكن هواتفنا ذكيه وكنا
ولم نكن كما نحن عليه الان اقل ذكاء
الى الهاتف وبدا بكتابه ابيات متناسبه مع
كل حرف ابجدي وبدا يبذر الجهد ليحفظ تلك
الابيات ليشارك عاما بعد عام هذه رحله
وهذا كرنفالو الاسري يتجدد في كل اجازه
وفي كل رحله طويله بالسياره فاصبح في
اعوامه الصغيره في عوام في السنوات
الابتدائيه يخوض ذلك الغمار شيئا فشيئا
وتجرا احيانا حتى الف بعض الابيات الشعريه
رقيقه لدرجه كانوا يكتشف امره باكرا هذا
الشعر ليس شعرا لكن العائله كانت تحتفي
بذلك الشعر احتفاء المعلقات وكان يشجع ذلك
الطفل يشجع ذلك الطفل على الاستمرار بما
هو عليه احب الفكره بذل جهدا بشغف
وباستمرار وتكونت لديه
او ربما تحفزت لديه
تحدث لديه كمون شعبي كان في في مكان ما في
عقله
وشاءت هذه الظروف هذه الصدفه الاسريه ان
يلد في عائله وفي بيئه تعنى بالشعر ان
يتحفز ذلك الكمون
فالنبت الصالح
ينمو بالعنايه وبالعنايه وبالعنايه وحدها
ينب النبت
بدا يكتب كما ذكرنا بعض القصائد وكان
لتشجيع الاسره اثر بالغ في تطوره او تطور
الكمون الشعري الذي
تكون لديهم نتابع في مشهدنا الثاني لهذه
القصه بذلك الطفل حين بدا ودخل الجامعه
دخل الى كليه الطب البشري في السنه الاولى
لكليه الطب ماده التشريح من المواد الجافه
نسبيا الصعبه في بعض الاحيان فيها الكثير
من المسميات على الطالب ان يحفظها بتكرار
وبتاعداد احيانا ممل
وفيها كثير من الاستذكار والحفظ فذلك
الطالب في الجامعه واجه صعوبه في حفظ
الاعصاب القحفيه ومرورها في ثقب قواعد في
ثقب قاعده القفز الاعصاب القحفيه مجموعه
اعصاب في الراس والعنق تعبر في ثقب موجوده
في قاعده الجمجمه ولكل عصب اسم عجيب ويمر
من ثقبه اسمها اعجب وعلى الطالب ان يحفظ
ذلك عن ظهر قلب فعليه ان يتذكر ان العصبه
الشمي يمر في الصفيحه المصفويه والعصب
البصري يعبر النفق البصري وفي الشق
الحجاجي العلوي لدي العصب الذي يحرك العين
محرك العين والعصب الفرع العيني من مثلث
التوائم والعصبان البكاري ومباعد العين
وهكذا احجيه جميله
فكتب ابياتها من الشعر قال فيها شمت
بمصفاه البصير بصائر شقت بحجتها حراك
الاعين وبكت بها عين التوائم بعدما دارا
مفك على ثقوب الكائن وهكذا استطاع ان
يتذكر ان شمت العصب الشمي يمر في بصفاته
في الصفيحه المصاويه البصير البصري بصائر
في النفق البصري شقت بحجتها في الشق
الحجاجي حراك الاعين محرك العين وبكت
البكري عين التوائم الفرع العين من مثلث
توائم بعدما مباعد العين وهكذا تطول او
تتعدد الابيات تتعدد الاعصاب وتتعدد الثقب
احب زملائه تلك القصائد او تلك الابيات
وساعدهم ذلك على استذكار هذه المشكله
التشريحيه وهذه الاعصاب وصعوبتهم
مرت الايام وتخرج ذلك الطالب من الجامعه
احب ماده التشريح حينما واجهها كانت ماده
صعبه فيه فيها بعض التحدي وبذل جهدا بشغف
مستمر ومتواصل جهد متواصل واصبح احيانا
يساعد زملائه في دراستي تلك الماده
مرت به الايام ودخل باختصاص جراحه لاحقا
تخرج من الكليه وفي مشهدنا الثالث
للقصه ذلك الطالب اصبح طبيبا يمارس
الجراحه وشاءت الصدف جاءت فرصه ان يعلن عن
تعيين اساتذه في الكليات
مسابقه المعيدين يسمونها ان يتقدم الطالب
بمسابقه الى وزاره وينتقى عدد من الطلاب
حسب ترتيب علاماتهم وجاءت الصدفه وشاء
الحظ ان يكون التشريح احد الاختصاصات
المطلوبه فتقدم الى اختصاص التشريح وهنا
وفد في مشهدنا الثالث الى فرنسا للحصول
على المؤهل العلمي المطلوب في فرنسا
ذلك المعيد المفرد طبعا من الصعوبه دائما
بدايه اختصاص في بلد غريب بثقافه غريبه
بذل جهد وصعوبات يعرفها كل من يتابع
تدريسه لم يكن الطريق ممهدا
مع الصعوبه استطاع ان يضع القطار على
السكه في فرنسا يدرسون التشريح حتى هذه
الايام بطريقه يعتبرونها طريقه اصيله
ويحبونها حبا جما هي طريقه السبوره
السوداء والطبشوره البيضاء او الطباشير
الملونه وما زالوا حتى هذه الايام يعتبرون
ان التدريس لا يمكن ان يدرس الا بهذه
الطريقه الكلاسيكيه
واي معضله تشريحيه يمكن دائما اسقاطها على
السبوره ورسمها بالطباشير سمع ان استاذا
فرنسيا في جامعه بعيده نسبيه عن مكاني
دراسته بدا باستخدام تقنيه جديده حيث يرسم
على لوحه رقميه ويتم اسقاط الرسم على
الشاشه فيساعد ذلك بنقل الصوره استقل
القطار استفسر عن مكان وجود ذلك الاستاذ
استقل القطار في وقت محاضراته وصل اليه
بجهد عرفه عن نفسه انه طالب سوري مفرد
لحساب جامعه دمشق وسيعود ليدرس التشريحه
فلم يكن ذلك مهما ابدا للاستاذ الفرنسي
يعني
وسمح له الجلوس على المقاعد ليتابع
المحاضره جلس شانه شان اي ضيف ثقيل وعلى
المقاعد استطاع ان يصور بعض الصور لما
يقوم به ذلك الاستاذ الفرنسي دون ان
يساعده ذلك الاستاذ ابدا باي معلومه تقنيه
للبرنامج المستخدم ولا اللوحه الرقميه كيف
نستخدمها ولا هي المفاتيح للوصول الى
المعلومه جاء بهذا التسجيل وحلله تحليل
الخبير لاحقا ولا خبره له بالموضوع كان
واستطاع التعرف على اسم البرنامج تعرف على
اللوحه طلب شرائها وبذل ساعات وساعات
طويله للتمكن من تلك الطريقه التي تعتبر
كانت طريقه حديثه نحن في العام 2008
تقريبا ولم تكن هذه الوسائل كما هي في
جيوبنا اليوم
ساعات طويله لا يمكن احصائها ويقولون
بالفرنسيه
عندما نحب شيئا ما لا نعد الساعات لا نعد
الدقائق ولا نعد الايام ولا السنين فالحب
والشغف هو الدافع حتى نقوم بعمل يعطي
نتيجه في النهايه وشاءت ايضا الصدف والفرص
ان يستطيع تطبيق تلك الطريقه في نطاق ضيق
في جامعته حيث يحضر الدكتوراه ولاحق ذلك
استحسانا وتشجيعا وكان نوعيا نوعا ما في
مشهدنا الرابع عاد ذلك الطالب الموف او
المعيد حاملا لما يؤهله للتدريس في جامعه
دمشق عاد الى الجامعه وبدا بتدريس ماده
التشريح وشاءت الصدف وشاءت الفرص وشاء
الحظ ان يتناقص عدد الاساتذه في الجامعه
تناقصا
متسارعا مطردا في احيانا على الاستاذ
عندما يعودنا الافاده ان ينتظر سنين
احيانا حتى يحصل على شرف القاء المحاضره
للطلاب حصل ذلك المعيد المفرد على ذلك
الشرف سريعا وكان ذلك الشرف كبيرا لجدا ان
انه بقي تقريبا او استلم تقريبا معظم
اجزاء الماده فكان ذلك تلك الفرصه الذهبيه
عندما كان طالبا كانت تمر في ذهنه احيانا
صور لماذا لا نعامل كما يجب ان نعامل
لماذا
لا تنقل لنا المعلومه كما نحب ان نتلقاها
دائما هناك حسرات بيمروا على الطالب عندما
يتلقى العلم بالطريقتين ليست الطريقه التي
يراها مناسبه فكانت تلك الفرصه الذهبيه
لذلك الطالب او لذلك الاستاذ
العائد من الافاده لكي يطبق كل ما حلم
بتطبيقه او رغبه بتطبيقه سابقا من وضع
الابيات الشعريه اثناء شرح المعضلات
التشريحيه الصعبه او استخدام الطرائق
التقنيه التي تسهل نقل المعلومه والتي
اصبحت الان هي الطريقه الشبه اليوميه في
اعطائي محاضرات التشريح فمثلا على سبيل
المثال في احدى المحاضرات
لدينا جذور عصبيه
تنشا منها الاعصاب
هنا الاعصاب القطنيه الاعصاب الرابع
والخامس والعجوز الاول العجوزه الثاني
العجزه الثالث العجزي الرابع مجموعه من
الاعصاب تعطي مجموعه من الضفائر العصبيه
الى تشكل اعصاب المحيطيه من الرابع
والخامس والاول ينشا لدينا عصبان اثنان
هما العصب الالوي العلوي
وعصب العضله المربعه الفخذيه
من الاعصاب الخامس والاول والثاني
ينشا ايضا عصبان اثنان هما العصب الالوي
السفلي
وعصب العضله السداديه الداخليه
في حين الاعصاب الاول والثاني والثالث
تشكل العصبه الذي يعصب جلد الفخذ من الخلف
الفخذي الجلدي الخلفي
الاعصاب الثاني والثالث والرابع
ستشكل ستشكل سويه عصبا هو العصب الحيائي
يعصب ناحيه الاجان وجميع هذه الاعصاب
تتضافر جهودها لتشكل اكبر عصب في الجسم
وهو العصب الوركي
فهذه الاعصاب المحيطيه للضفيره العجوزيه
نستطيع ببيت الشعر الذي بدانا به
تقديمنا والى العلا
مر السفيه
بسيد
جلدت تخلف
بالحياء
فابوريا
[تصفيق]
فالى العلا العصب الالوي العلوي مره عصب
المربعه الفخذيه اسسيه العصب الالوي
السفلي بسيدا عصب السداديه الداخليه جلد
التخلف العصب الفخذي الجلدي الخلفي
بالحياء العصب الحيائي فبورك العصب الوركي
خلاصه القصه
احيانا تاتي صدف ليست متوقعه في حياه اي
منا صدفه ان يولد احد في عائله تحب الادب
لكن الجهد هو الذي يجعلنا نغتنم تلك
الفرصه او تلك الصدفه
لمره واحده لا يكفي
الجهد يجب ان يكون متواصلا مستداما ودائما
الفرصه وجهت
ياتيان بالنتيجه والجهد المتواصل
لكنهما لن ياتيا بنفس النتيجه التي ياتي
بها التي تاتي بها الفرصه مع الجهد
المتواصل مع الشغف والشغف في سلم ترتيب
مراتب الحب في فقه اللغه هو مرتبه الوسطى
بين العلاقه والهوى وبين الجنون والتبتل
علينا ان نكون وسطيين وان نحب ما نعمل
عليه نعمل بشغف ان نعمل بشغف وبجهد متواصل
لنستثمر فرصه قد تمر مرور الكلام دون ان
نستثمرها ودون ان يشعر بها احد ذلك الطفل
الذي شاء الصدفه او الفرصه ان يلد في
عائله تحب الادب وبذل الجهد ليحفظ الشعر
واحب ذلك العمل بشغف ذلك الطالب الذي احب
ماده التشريح وبذل الجهد لكي يت وعمل على
تمكن منها بشغف ذلك الاستاذ المفرد الذي
سمع بطريقه جديده بالتدريس احبها وبذل
جهدا كبيرا حتى يتمكن منها وذلك الاستاذ
الذي عاد ليدرس الطلاب
وبذل الجهد ليتمكن من المعلومه التشريحيه
ويقدم كل ما كان يحلم ان يقدم له في زمانه
وعمل على ذلك بشغف واستمرار يشكر لكم حسن
اسقائكم